In this video, we'll go back over everything we learned in this course
and give you some jumping off points for further exploration.
So, what have we covered today?
We've translated Unity concepts and terms into their Unreal Engine counterparts.
We exported our assets from Unity as FBXs and imported them into Unreal.
We recreated logic contains within scripts and animation controllers that couldn't make the jump.
We then also rebuilt materials and player interactions that didn't come through.
Next, we were able to hone our look and feel through the use of post-processing and lighting.
And we've learned about some of Unreal Engine's unique features like level blueprints,
material parameter collections, and some of the features of Unreal's modeling mode.
Finally, we packaged our project into an executable file that we can share with the world.
For next steps, there's a number of things you can do to take your project further.
For example, you could try using the enhanced input system for player input,
which allows for several different keys across gamepads, keyboards, et cetera,
to all create the same interactive sequences in Unreal.
Also, you can try using the sequencer in Unreal Engine to drive other kinds of animation,
environmental changes, et cetera.
This can be done with cameras and animating assets to a greater degree
than what we brought over from Unity.
You can also try additional world-building tools using the landscape tools,
as well as things like foliage, trees.
Unreal has a very robust system for painting and creating these kinds of environments.
You can also try creating or modifying the visual effects in the project using Niagara,
which is the more advanced particle system in Unreal Engine,
if you want to go beyond what you might have done with, say, the VFX graph in Unity.
You can also try adding a UI, which might include elements like a quit button,
using the UMG system in Unreal, which is how we create widgets
and other kinds of HUDs and overlays.
You can also try going into FAB and importing Unity assets from there
directly into Unreal to understand how that pipeline might work.
Additionally, there is the USD file format,
which stands for Universal Scene Description, developed by friends at Pixar,
and that is becoming a more and more common industry standard
for bringing 3D data from one DCC application to another,
both Unreal Engine and Unity support USD
with the appropriate plugins and packages enabled.
And so that might be another way to move between these programs,
especially if you want to go back and forth,
because it can actually be nondestructive,
and you can modify the USD file without needing to export it
or change things as you go between your DCC applications.
And then, of course, the FAB marketplace is full of a very large number of tools
which can benefit both the Unity and Unreal Engine pipelines.
So anything that you might want to do across either of those applications,
there is a good chance that FAB has something you need,
whether it be on the coding and interactive side
or just general assets.
Thank you for joining us today.
We hope you found this helpful and learned a lot,
and we look forward to seeing you in a future course.
And Whit and I both wish you luck on your Unreal Engine journey.